what's up believe nation how we do and
good morning it is 654 here on the East
Coast the Sun has not come out yet so
it's still kind of dark in here I turned
on my computer and notice that we are at
899 and 977 subscribers and I thought I
wanna hop on see who's awake and do a
livestream and answer some questions see
what's up so for however long it takes
us to hit 23 more subscribers I'm gonna
do a live screen and answer some
questions hey Meg are he shown 100
morning to zabita a Bristow it's it's
1624 in Sri Lanka's Congo going million
so this is cool man it's a 425 away
eight nine nine nine seven five if you
guys have any quick questions let me
know will answer couple Nina's not awake
yet so I'm gonna be a little bit on the
Commerce side because I don't want to
wake her up got the door closed but I'll
see what you got mitko is that Steve
Jobs post when you're right yeah that's
Steve Jobs I guess I could switch it we
got jobs Steve Jobs Howard Schultz
Starbucks my parents and me when I was
eight AP Giannini started Bank of
America in the Kanye West at the fire
back there what else
hi give a daily ritual extras do you
have any daily ritual exercise for
better speaking from kami kami do I have
him now not as much I used to I used to
when I was really building that up and
when when I was getting like that was my
big goal and a better speaker I would do
two three times a day I'd be making new
videos working on them analyzing them
sending them to my agent getting
feedback send them to friends getting
feedbacks you know kind of improve go go
go go go and see what we do to get
better you know I'm going to share my
screen here I want to share my screen so
that you guys can follow
along the live chat with me actually you
know what let me put the can I do the
live let's see we got another live one
and that's ones not so that this is it
caught me by surprise it we're gonna do
it today like all right let's go why not
answer some questions help some
entrepreneurs let me share my screen so
you guys can see there's a green button
share screen alright there we go now you
guys can check out how we're doing we're
getting close in close twenty seven
subscribers away so morning ritual for
speaking or daily ritual
I used to write I would make a couple
videos a day getting feedback from
everybody now I'm helping train Lily if
you guys have watched the unlocking
Lily's series I've been doing that and
she's been working pretty much every day
making content for her channel for my
channel I'm practicing like for one
video for my channel she'll do a hundred
takes so it's a lot of work like it's a
lot of work a lot of work a lot of work
constantly hustling to get it going next
what do we got positive legend any time
management skills please I'm too lazy so
I'll be lazy about it's about having
important goals about feeling like the
work you're doing is important we've all
had moments of laziness we've all had
moments of being on fire and being
unstoppable I'm sure you have had times
in your life where you felt unstoppable
and amazing and it's finding out what
triggers that if you wake up and you're
not excited about your day and you feel
like it doesn't matter if you're doing
anything today or not then guess what
you won't but if you wake up and feel
like hey I've had something important
that I need to do today the work I'm
doing matters I'm excited about
something then you'll do it it's not as
much time management as fixing your
goals that you're not as lazy next
Kimberly fared you have any tips for
someone who doesn't believe they deserve
more that's a hard one it's why it's why
my one word is believe and why I want to
spread more of that to the world I think
the best way that
you can do it is to start to change your
environment the thing that really helped
me more as much as possible believe more
of myself in what I could do was my
content
there's the videos like I'm surrounding
myself with intention with people who've
done a lot more than me and you can
learn a lot by just reading books and by
listening to some advice and getting to
how to's but I think for a lot of this
stuff for for belief for self confidence
to follow a guide of here the seven ways
to get more confidence it might give you
some some practical tips but I think
just being around the confidence makes
you more confident and so I learned just
as much by just watching these famous
people super successful people seeing
how they're confident and that just
rubbed off on me and and the story that
I've told a couple times I like to tell
is when I was in the car with my dad we
were going up to get a new car for him
and I had just done a deal with Stephen
Kelly from Sage and here's this guy
who's got you know 15,000 employees and
billions in revenue and he's oh we just
jumped nine nine ninety one that's good
ninety-two eighteen more 18 more I like
it
here's this guy who had all the success
and and I was doing a live Q&A with him
when I was answering questions alongside
him and my father asked me well how do
you have the self belief to feel like
you're on the same level as him and be
able to not be intimidated by him this
huge CEO and it wasn't trying to put me
down he was just in he was in awe he was
happy for me and I said I had to think
about it
because I wasn't really nervous or
scared doing the session with Stephen
and a lot of that came because what I
hang out with daily like I'm hanging
around Steve Jobs Daley and Warren
Buffett Daley and Bill Gates Daley and
Howard Schultz Daley and Oprah Winfrey
Delia's people who inspire me as people
who build me up and just seeing them do
great things gives me the confidence and
do more great things I think you're in
really matters and so I would encourage
you to think about the people that make
you have that self-confidence if you've
watched any of the top tens or or videos
not on my channel just in general
anything that's made you feel confident
and bold and courageous and then doing
more of that incorporating that into
your daily routine you know if if
watching an Oprah Winfrey video is a
thing that gets you really feeling bold
and excited then then watch it Oprah
Winfrey video every morning because if
you start it every day feeling
courageous and bold just imagine you did
every day for a year your life will be
unrecognizable from what it is today
you'll you'll have so much growth over
the next year it'll be insane but most
of us start and stop and start and stop
and you have a moment of boldness once a
week or once a month and you don't have
the consistency to keep through on it so
I think that's that's important next
cyber wolf guys please try to increase
Evan subscribers that big guy deserves a
lot more than he has thank you for the
love cyber wolf I really appreciate all
you guys and all the constant love that
comes in and support from everybody I
deserve what I have though you know like
I I deserve to have nine hundred
thousand subscribers or almost there
because of all the hard work and all the
all the hopefully quality content you
guys are enjoying but I also don't
deserve more yet either you know I don't
deserve to have a million or nine
million or whatever the next milestone
is and that's okay like I need to get
better right the videos need to get
better the research needs to get better
everything that I do on the channel
needs to get better it's been a fun
hustle over the past couple of years
building this channel up and I'm
grateful for what I have and I and I
deserve that in a good way
but I also don't deserve more I need to
work hard for it and so I think at least
that's my approach that I try to take
towards these things next who day what
what's your secret to success
well there's a number of them I think
the one that's worked the most for me
and the one that is most common from all
the videos that I put together all the
research I've done
oh it's made a big jump 980 515 more
subscribers guys 15 more oh we hit 900
the biggest one is just following your
passion doing the thing that you're most
excited about like I love helping
entrepreneurs this is just something in
my eye my twitter livestream at 7 in the
morning all Nina's sleeping you know
like I love I love helping entrepreneurs
I love learning about entrepreneurship
I love DJing content together I just
love doing it and you'll find that the
people who love what they do are the
ones who had the most success and the
people who jump in like there's a lot of
people will jump in on an opportunity
because I think it's a hot thing you'll
get crushed you know if you if you try
to jump in and be a youtuber but you're
not really passionate about it you're
just trying to be famous you don't
really have an interest or you think
it's a way to make a lot of money you'll
get crushed
you'll get crushed by the youtubers who
actually have a serious passion for what
they're doing and to same in any field
whether you want to be an athlete the
musician and entrepreneur there are
people who love what they're doing and
are working tirelessly to to do it like
I got up at 4:30 this morning started
working couldn't sleep started working
here we go let's do it and so those
people will crush you and by the same
token on the positive side you will
crush others in an area that you love
and so you got to find the thing that
you absolutely love doing even if it
doesn't make any sense
when I started doing this I wasn't
making any money nobody was showing up
to free things I was putting on and you
know three people showed up to my first
thing and it just made me feel like I
want to I loved helping those three
people and even if I never found the way
to make money I need to keep doing it
and that's the thing you need to find
that you would do for free because the
work fulfills you next so we got high I
mean what's your favorite feel blog
what's my favorite blog I
know that I have a favorite blog I don't
know that I read anybody's blog anymore
I used to follow Darrin rouse and Zen
habits and a few other in the
entrepreneur space but I think I've just
been I just would much rather with much
rather consume videos than read a vlog a
blog and I just think the quality or the
caliber of the ideas and the people can
be higher like if Steve Jobs was writing
the blog I would read that blog but is
not and so you're maybe learning from
somebody way further down at Apple and
you just extrapolate across like you can
get a lot of ideas from Elon Musk but
does he have a blog now so I'd rather
learn from the people who've had the
most success than from the people
further down and I much I'm a more
visual person so I don't I don't know
what do you what do you guys like who
are your favorite bloggers I don't I
don't I don't know I don't think I've
read a blog for past couple years what
else million a Horry is here love your
workouts millionaire Horry has a ton of
energy a ton of love if you're trying to
get fit I would definitely recommend
checking out his channel he's got got
some cool stuff happening there what
else Evan how do you treat unpleasant
experiences in difficult moments from
the past um you know I don't let the I
don't spend much time thinking about the
past just as a general rule I don't know
why it's not a conscious thing I just I
don't it doesn't serve me well I forget
about a lot of things people always ask
me like how when did you set this
channel how old were you and how long
have you been around and I don't even
remember I don't know when I started
this I don't I don't think backwards
I don't think about previous milestones
that much good to like good ones as well
not just bad ones I don't think about
the good stuff that happened in the past
either have very focused on like what's
happened right now and where I want to
go and so the negative things that have
happened I'm sure they taught me lessons
a lot but I don't I don't keep
you know if you look at the YouTube
channel we've we've canceled more series
and then are on the channel right now
like there's been tons of series that
I've loved that maybe you guys member
maybe you don't you know they didn't
they didn't hit you guys didn't like
them enough so we cancelled them and I
liked a lot of them but I couldn't name
them to you right now
you know I just I don't think about it I
think it the more time you spend
thinking about other people worrying
about the past focus on the things that
you can't do it's not it's not a great
place to be you know it doesn't help you
get to where you want to go and so I
just don't spend time thinking about it
if that was a big problem for you I
would try back to my advice before about
how to increase your belief self believe
self confidence to surround yourself
with the content and the people and the
ideas that let you let go of that you
know if you're if you're hanging around
people who are only talking about the
past and negativity and the things that
happen and complaining about their how
they grew up and all those you know
negative reasons then you're gonna be
the same way but if you're hanging
around people who are grateful and
successful and trying to do big things
then you're gonna that's gonna rub off
on you right so the the things that you
surround yourself forth that's what you
become just like you're the product of
your five closest friends then you may
say well I don't have I don't have
friends that are successful who think
that way all of people around me or
complainers and they don't know what
they're doing great that's where for me
that's where the aspirational mentorship
comes in that's where the videos come in
right I don't have any super successful
entrepreneurs around me I don't know
anybody
I'm also introverted so I don't go out
to a lot of events and conferences and
introduce myself to try to make those
connections how I learned and how I
gained the confidence and India's
through the through my videos to the
content for the research and so if
there's somebody that you watch or
somebody that you read that you then
feel like you don't care about the past
anymore you can let it go
then again start your day with that
every day make that part of your daily
routine your daily habits and bit by bit
by bit you will change and care less
about those things that happen to you in
the past need a quick sip of water here
ten more eight nine nine nine oh eight
nine nine nine nine alright next what do
we got Pow Wow hey Evan I just want to
say that I listened to you I'd like to
listen to your channel great job thanks
for the love Powell I like that little
cartoon never tire you have valley did
your health suffer on the road to
success did my health suffer on my road
to success not not in a major way the
only incident I could really think about
was when I took over Toronto dance also
when I acquired the business I had to
run to business at the same time and I
didn't build the team at Toronto dance
salsa I inherited a team where in my
business I built my team and I built it
solely but I built one piece from one
piece of one I didn't go and raise a
million dollars and then hire a team on
that once I built them one at a time and
so you get to pick the people you want
and you know you slowly develop them
with TDS ie I I picked Alex to run the
company helped me run it but everybody
else I inherited and they're all great
they're all great people but I didn't
have a relationship with them much
before I was an investor in the company
but I didn't have you know I didn't have
a friendship or a solid relationship
with them and so it took a lot of work
to get to know them to understand them
to deal with their stresses and when
somebody is is stressed out around me I
I can get stressed out too like I'll eat
their stress I'll feel it with them and
then try to help them solve it which I
think can help in terms of being a
leader who people feel like you get them
but doing that with too many people at
the same time impacted my own health and
I suffered I had to go see a doctor I
had stress pills like stress pills I
never get stressed out to the point
where I need stress pill that was crazy
so
I had stress feels for like a week is
that okay well this has to change and I
just made adjustments that was really
the only time I think that I've really
had health becoming a Hugh and it wasn't
even that serious I think what I find
really helpful is to do a regular
inventory of your life and this is
something I've done for a long time I
constantly looking up how I'm spending
my time what's in my calendar what I'm
doing each day it's like this is Friday
this is my CEO day I'm gonna spend a lot
of time working with with my big
projects and I evaluate where I'm at as
a entrepreneur as a father as a husband
you know in all the areas that I find
are important and I'll constantly check
and see like am i doing enough is this
you know is the time I'm spending with
Nyna enough are we spend enough quality
time together is my you know we started
working out at the beginning of last
year this year I don't you remember now
so yeah I don't look backwards I don't
have we want to you know get healthier
you know physically like with our with
our endurance with our strength and so
we did we hired a personal trainer and
sort of worked on that together and so I
would say I don't sit down once a week
or once a month and with intention look
at look at my calendar and say okay this
this let me think how are things going
it's more when I started to feel like
something's a little bit out of whack
you know I'm spending I really want to
work on this new thing but I don't have
time right not having time as an excuse
not having time as you know priorities
and so if I want to work on something I
don't have the time then I know I need
to adjust my schedule to make it work
and again personal husband/father as
well as being an entrepreneur and so I
think if you do that regularly then you
have all these little kind of micro
moments of hmm this isn't working I need
to change it as opposed to waiting for
some major life macro thing to happen
right like you have a heart
or something really negative happens to
you I think if you're constantly
evaluating where you are and where you
want to go and does your schedule and
your actions kind of map to you
accomplishing that goal if you're doing
that constantly then you're more likely
to not fall off the track and not get
massively sick either
next heat and jolly did it take did you
take you some time to muster courage and
put out your first youtube video so when
I started on YouTube YouTube wasn't a
huge thing like people weren't becoming
massive YouTube celebrities I never
really wanted to be YouTube famous it
was just about trying to create content
to help some entrepreneurs it was a
combination of one I love the idea of
modeling success even from like all the
way back to the beginning of this
channel if you go back you'll see I love
the I love the idea of modeling success
and I wanted to share that with others
because that saved my company and I
wanted to make it easier for other
people who are getting started and so
that's let's save my business and so I
made some videos about that and then
also people were emailing me and I was
writing these long responses back and I
thought maybe I could just make a video
and respond to that person instead of
writing these 30 40 minute long emails
you know like when you get one or two a
day it's flattering it makes you feel
good oh somebody spending the time to
write to me but when you're getting more
and more and more I thought okay if
somebody has this problem other people
have it too why don't I make a video it
wasn't really a big huge scary thing
well eight nine nine nine nine eight
wow that's a big jump social blade let's
go to more guys it wasn't a big scary
thing but I also didn't have big
expectations either you know I think a
lot of times when we start something we
we have to have a workout it has to be
our next big thing eight nine nine nine
nine nine and there it is nine hundred I
love that thank you guys that that was
great let's stop it nine hundred
thousand okay again we can't get too
crazy cuz Nina's sleeping and it's still
7:00 in the morning
still getting been up for a couple hours
but I'm still getting my amp
my juice going so I think I think a lot
of times we set these expectations for
this has to work and and then when it
doesn't or when you're first getting
started at it you you put so much
pressure on yourself that then you need
to muster tons of courage but when I
first started it's like here's something
I'm gonna try you know it's like you're
gonna go to a restaurant you're gonna
try a new kind of food do you need to
muster up tons of courage well maybe if
you've heard a lot of negative things
about it or you're allergic to it or you
know there's some story behind it you do
but otherwise I could I'll try it why
not see how it goes so I think whenever
you have an idea to try something the is
good to think big but just take small
steps the more you can just start just
try something take away the pressure the
longer you wait the more of a story you
build up in your head then the more
difficult becomes and then the more you
need to summon this crazy courage to do
it but it's just hey you know how about
I try you to by the Malon should I
should I think everybody should give it
a shot I think everybody should try
YouTube everybody should try
entrepreneurship just like you should
try sushi like try it once in your life
if it doesn't mean you'll like it and be
addicted but try it and see and so if
you take that approach to a lot of the
things in life without putting up huge
expectations on yourself then it's a lot
easier to be to be a success because a
lot of times would make that fear so big
that then we don't do anything then you
don't think any action and you sit on it
like how long have you wanted to have a
youtube channel you sell it for weeks
and then months and then years and then
what happens is you lose a lose the
window like YouTube won't be the thing
forever right there's gonna be something
else that comes along that becomes a new
thing and so you will miss your
opportunity to do the thing you want to
do if you don't take action right now
and so break it down to the smallest
possible step the big goal the big dream
you have the smallest possible step and
do that do that right now
Thunder bunny it will do a couple more
we'll wait for Nina to wake up
under Bunny how can you get better
communication while being shy so listen
I'm shy I'm introverted I don't go
talking to people randomly
I hate networking events I think the
advantage that you have as being an
introverted shy person is you listen
more and communication is about not just
not just talking your face off but being
able to understand what the other person
is saying and giving them value
especially as an entrepreneur and so I
think that's our advantage in our
weakness is not being willing or able to
talk but our advantage is we can hear
better and we can listen better we can
understand better and so for me when I'm
talking to people first off I create a
model where people come to me so I have
this YouTube channel right you guys are
sending me questions so I'm just
answering them it's a lot easier I don't
go to networking events but I'll speak
at events and as as the speaker people
that come up afterwards and ask me
questions and so that creates a lot of
dialogue but I won't go up and shake
their hands and say introduce myself at
the beginning and say hey I'm Evan I'm
speaking here how are you I would never
do that and so focusing on the marketing
side as opposed to the sales side so
that you are bringing people to you
whether you're doing advertising whether
you're making content whether you're
posting to your website or social media
so that you get incoming I find that a
lot easier then I just try to focus on
it not being about me but being about
them so just thinking about how can I
help this person what are they trying to
accomplish whether they're an
entrepreneur or whether to just somebody
who has a question or whether it's just
somebody trying to you know make small
talk how can I help this person and as
soon as I make it about them and not me
then you can also especially when I was
younger and trying to figure this out
you let go of the insecurities and fear
of saying the wrong thing or being
judged or not knowing what to do because
it's not about you anymore it's about
just trying to make that person feel
good or
reach a goal or get information and then
again similar advice to the other
questions if it's really goal of yours
and I would study people who communicate
in the style that you want so we
profiled a lot of different speakers on
my channel as an example and you've got
you've got the guys who will yell at you
right you've got Eric Thomas and Gary
Vaynerchuk and Joe Rogan and Jaco
willing and guys who will just like
scream at you to go do something and
that's great for some people and some
people need that they need that really
hard push and then you've got Wayne Dyer
and brené Brown and a bunch of other
people who have a much softer side and
maybe that's what resonates with you and
so I would find the person that or group
of people that you really feel like man
I really like how they communicate and
it's not that they're right and
everybody else is wrong it just fits for
your style better and then just think of
how do I consume more of that content
because the more you watch the more you
watch a Gary Vee the more you'll be like
Gary Vee right the more you watch Bernie
brand the more you'll be like Bernie
Brown
it was partly why I want to have so many
different people on my channel so many
people that we profile cuz I want to
pull the best at least for me from all
these people record something from Steve
Jobs is different than Howard Schultz
and and everybody else so I think that's
really important I think I think those
things will help what else Nikolas loves
love's Jocko Jacques was great we tried
to do a collaboration together he was
travelling at the time when we did I
think it was his mentor me dick was
mentoring me video yeah he's great he's
great and and I think as you so this I
think is an important point when you
when you're first starting you may
resonate strongly with you may hate
Jocko willing you may think like this
guy's you know he swears too much is in
your face too much he just yells at me
too much I don't like that
I like Wayne Dyer who's softer and
soulful and and at the start great go
learn from Wayne
as you continue to grow though you'll
find and I find that you'll get a lot of
the best lessons from the people who you
initially don't agree with or find their
style off-putting it doesn't mean that
you have to become like them but you can
still pull something from them to be a
better version of you it's like why is
Kanye at my wall back there
Kanye does a lot of stupid things right
Kanye puts his foot in his mouth really
often and in you know I think often says
things without thinking about them which
is the opposite of me I'm always if
anything hyper focused on saying
something that I mean and I rarely
apologize for things that I say because
I mean everything that I say even if
it's a harsh truth so why is Kanye up on
my wall well there's also a lot of
greatness in Kanye that can help make me
better and a lot of people have a hard
time looking past just one side of that
person you know Steve Jobs you may have
been not the greatest father and not the
greatest husband and not the greatest
boss so great I'm not going to learn
parenting skills and advice from Steve
Jobs but there's a lot of other saying
things that I can pull from him to help
me be a better entrepreneur and so just
that concept of if somebody's had
success you can learn something from
them even if 95% of what they say
doesn't resonate with you or is even
toxic to you you can still learn for
another 5% and so it's partly why I
profile so many different people
sometimes controversial people cuz I
learned something from them and hope you
guys came to Paulo Congrats when will
the recording be available as soon as
this is done YouTube takes around half
an hour so to process a video and then
you can watch the whole thing if you
want Steve Jobs is a true legend yes I
agree you know one of the all-time
greats in entrepreneurship
I'm thinking about making a video about
like the the entrepreneur dream team if
you had to build a company not that
these guys would ever even work together
but who would be the CEO and and who
would be the
the CIO and the seat you know chief
marketing officer and the head of HR you
know who would who would fill those
roles right like jobs you wouldn't put
as the tech guy it's the marketing guy
but probably not the CEO so I don't know
I'm thinking about it might do a video
sharing my personal favorites and I'm
asking you guys what you think to role
hi Donald hrus you did a lot of research
my question is how many hours successful
people sleep per day uh sleep is a
tricky one I think everybody has to find
their rhythm you know today I didn't
sleep that well I was up at 4:30 you
went to bed at 11 ish I usually sleep
seven to eight hours I don't think the
hours sleeping really is the the biggest
thing whether you're sleeping you know
six hours or eight hours brings it to
our difference it's more what are you
doing with the other 16 hours at you're
awake I think a lot of people too often
default to I need to sleep less to
accomplish my goals
no you're just wasting a ton of time
during the day like if you if you are
forcing yourself to sleep fewer hours
and you need and you're going through
the day super tired you're not gonna be
massively productive that's not the
answer it's what are you doing for the
other 16 hours in the day like are you
taking long lunch breaks are you surfing
Facebook you know when you should be
working are you you know watching TV
episodes back-to-back and just junking
out are you trying to escape a life that
you don't like instead of building a new
one I think I think most people aren't
so we're productive during the day you
have a couple hours of like maybe good
productivity and the rest and so I don't
think the answer is to default to
sleeping less I think it's you should
start with being productive in the hours
that you're awake
next Purusha Evan what software do you
use to get the work do you use to get to
the work I don't know what I don't know
what specifically you're asking there
this right now I'm just using Google
it's free from Google through YouTube
from my editing stuff I don't I don't
know I don't edit my videos anymore I
started with Windows Movie Maker my
first ones then I moved to Camtasia and
then I hired an editor and so whatever
she uses it's not don't worry about the
tools the tools don't matter unless your
the tools person then they do matter but
if you're trying to make content like I
am the tools don't matter you know I
love my team I love my camera guy I love
my editor I'm the most important piece
and that's not from like Eagle point of
view it's a pressure point of view like
if I sock then everything falls apart
because you can have the best tools and
the best camera and if the content sucks
doesn't make a difference
next kami tree I want to be a life coach
and a speaker but I don't know which
career is better for my goals I have two
options in life marketing or psychology
which one do you recommend whenever
you're faced with the situation where
you have two seemingly opposite paths i
recommend your best option is going to
be trying to incorporate both its
embrace the genius of the and find a way
to do both because if you just do
marketing you're always gonna have this
piece that's like I am you know I wish I
could do psychology it's always gonna be
that piece that's missing and if you
it's same thing the other way just who
psyche you're gonna feel kind of wish it
did someone marketing and if you can
combine both of them there's a lot of
psychology and marketing is a lot of
marketing psychology right like if you
can combine both of them then you're
different you're unique that's how you
stand out you know for me I'm DJing
content which has been done before and
I'm doing it for Entrepreneurship which
hasn't really been done before like I
started making my videos with the the
profile in different entrepreneurs
because nobody was doing it like I
didn't want to make these videos I wish
somebody wish you guys did it and I
could just subscribe to your channel
I would have to do the work but nobody
did it so I did it and so you'll often
find the best opportunities come with
the intersection of multiple interests
and passions that you have so this is a
good thing and I think if you go with
both you have a much higher chance of
being successful than if you just try to
pick one because it's not really
embracing your full potential I think
about a buddy mind I've told the start
couple times but he's a financial
adviser and he was he loved financial
advising he loved helping people manage
their money and invest and save for the
future and he also loved hockey Canadian
you know we love our hockey I'm more of
a baseball fan but he loved this hockey
and he was the kind of guy I could watch
the same replay on on TV of a goal
scored eight times and still be in love
with it and so you may think those are
totally different things like hockey and
financial advising how do they even come
close to hi Nina
I'm doing a livestream how did they even
come close to relating like at least for
you you've got marketing psychology
which are close for him they seem
totally opposite but what he ended up
doing was becoming the financial advisor
for NHL hockey players so these guys
have money right they need to be able to
invest it and the difference was when
other financial advisors go talk to the
NHL players they're just talking money
and they're not huge fans of the sport
when he goes in he can talk money and he
can talk about man that goal you scored
last night that was sick I watched it
eight times on SportsCenter last night
and so he wins because he can use his
multiple passions in a way that others
can't and so he'll beat the people who
only care about financial advising and
so that's the thing you can find a niche
where you can combine psychology and
marketing where you will beat other
people in that niche because all they
care about is marketing or all they care
about is psychology and you know both
that's where you win
what else King David Rives how do you
know when you are ready to hire your
first employee and how much do you pay
them I hate spending money telling
making money so I know when I'm ready to
hire my first employee when I'm making a
little bit of money and then I also
don't hire full-time at the beginning I
would start by my first hire was one
hour a day I paid the guy one hour a day
to do work that saved me an hour and a
half a day because he was better at it
than I was and allowed me to move up to
do more CEO level stuff instead of doing
the work that he was doing and so I'd
look at am I making any kind of money if
not then it's on you to I want all
invest my time my energy my heart my
hustles I'm passionate about it into
this new idea even starting youtube I
did everything myself I had a successful
business I had my website it was growing
I had a team there I had money coming in
I started on YouTube who spent 0 I
borrowed the camera once I pardon with a
friend to make a video and most of them
I just made off of my own camera and I
edited it myself so that's how I default
until I'm making money or until I lose
passions but lots of projects where I
tested something like huh I didn't like
that so I'm done with it or you tried a
couple times and you lose the interest
and so I kill it so that's how I do it
and so I'd be looking at ok get get
somebody coming in then look at the task
that you're doing that you don't like
and that you never want to be good at
you never care about like editing for me
I respect it it's needed but I never
want to be good at it I never want to be
world-class at editing so I could be if
I wanted to but I don't so I'm not so I
need to hire that out so you figure that
out ok
what's that yeah I'm doing a live stream
I know this there's there's a hundreds
of people here I'm doing
I'm doing a livestream because I hit
900,000 I hit 9,000 like half an hour
ago today livestream showing my screen
okay yeah tons people ask me questions
there it's a chat it's not it's not an
interview anyway alright is any you're
getting love Nina people say love to
Nina you're getting happy faces and
hearts okay I'm gonna do one more
question that again you'll spend time
with my wife
give her a morning hug and get on my
morning routine last question what do
you got guys what are we gonna do last
question last question lots of love for
Nina good we are asking for Nina Nina
gets him and musica change for sure come
on what else question
she doesn't know same livestream she
does just woke up listen you're probably
not the most alert when you wake up -
okay next last question here it is mo mo
hood Chiba and I hope I pronounced that
properly
what percentage of money does a
co-founder take from a company and what
goes to others we need a video on this
topic it's a hard one because there's no
one answer you know what ends up
happening with with co-founders almost
always if somebody's working harder than
somebody else you know at the beginning
everybody's gung-ho and it makes sense
on paper right it's like you're gonna do
this and I'm gonna do this and our our
skills work out really well together so
let's go off and do this thing together
AHA right but then as you get into it
you're gonna hit crappy times like it's
gonna suck you're gonna make mistakes
you're not gonna make money for a while
and then you're gonna find that one
person's really carrying the load where
other people aren't right just like I
think about my university in high school
group projects right like you always
have somebody who does the work and
there's always one person who's like who
slacks off and you have to carry them
and so that becomes a big problem in a
lot of these when you trying to figure
out how people are going to get paid one
you want to make sure you work
people who you've worked with before or
you have a good relationship with and
you can have an open conversation with
just because somebody has the right
skill set doesn't mean they're right
partner for you you have to share the
same values which may mean you need to
adjust a compensation like to be able to
have a good discussion is saying listen
I'm putting in more work than you I
don't think this is a fair split and not
have that become this massive fight is
important so I think where a lot of
people start off is like hey let's do
5050 you have have I have to reach
putting equal work but then you'll
quickly get frustrated at some point and
so do you then have a discussion and
adjust do you not allow anybody in and
make them earn their equity in like if
you start the business by yourself and
they have to earning or they have to buy
in there's no one model and that's
that's the problem that's why it's all
so hard to make a video on it because
it's so specific to your situation
partnerships are rough you know I was in
a partnership my first business I joined
there are two co-founders and I was a
third owner and they gave me equity in
the business I didn't I didn't earn in
and luckily it worked like the three of
us worked really well together we
actually tried bringing in a fourth
partner who didn't work out well and
luckily we were able to kind of kill the
arrangement before before signing the
deal with him we got lucky and and so
you know for me that first deal worked
out but I'm also really lucky
look we communicated well we all put in
equal amounts of work it worked but it
doesn't happen for most people like that
most people aren't as equally committed
and dedicated ever since though I
haven't had partnerships I've owned the
business every business that I've done
or I've invested into the business I
guess that's kind of like a partnership
but you're investing capital not
as much time and I've given people
incentives to perform right so it could
be a percentage of revenue a percentage
of profit or certain milestones to hit
but I've always owned the equity in
future businesses I think a lot of us
because it's finding the right people
and also I've seen so many horror
stories with other people that I need to
really you need to really have a good
connection with the people on your team
that have those open discussions you'll
make it work I've seen entren I was
talking to with Daisy Friday yesterday
and he has a business and he started off
a business I had a partner and had 5050
and realized that they were both working
hard but they both had different
ambitions they both want to take the
company in different directions they
started two years ago had some success
had the same vision but then wanted to
you know two years later they get into
arguments of where they want to take the
company and decided that they need to
kind of figure out a new model and so
he's taking 100% ownership of the
business and he's given his partner ten
percent of revenue for the business
which is actually it that's a tight deal
at the beginning that's not bad if
you're making half a million in revenue
you're you're earning fifty thousand
that's not bad but if you're making two
million you're paying them two hundred
thousand your margins may not be able to
support that so doing revenue percentage
deals can also be a dangerous path to
follow so I hope that answers the
question kind of all over the place but
really it's finding finding making sure
the person you have has shared values
that you could have a discussion with
that things get tough then you're going
to be able to adjust a deal if needed
and then to trying to really make an
assessment of who's bringing what to the
table how much work everybody's doing
what the value is that that person's
work is bringing and if you can't have
an honest discussion like if honestly if
you're bringing more value than your
partner right if you if you're gonna
even if you're working the same number
of hours if you're gonna bring more
value through your experience for your
connections through everything else
maybe you deserve 75% of the business
if you can't have that kind of honest
conversation at the start of the
relationship like good luck having it
two years in that's just not gonna
happen you're gonna lose a huge fight or
lead to lawsuits or and it's just not
worth it so interesting question
thank you guys to the love it's awesome
to be here at nine hundred thousand
whenever hitting these milestones I
never know you know I never know where
I'm gonna be because you know it's not
like it's gonna happen a specific time
I'm gonna try to do something bigger
around the million but sometimes it's
like in the middle of night there
sometimes I have meetings or sometimes
I'm out of the country so I was real I
was really lucky that I woke up at 4:30
this morning and that yeah you need to
know woke up before 3:00 this morning I
was lucky and I came on and I saw that
we were hitting it we're getting close
and we could do this together so
otherwise if I woke up normally I don't
know if I'd have the energy or open eyes
miss enough to be able to do it but
thank you guys for the love you're a big
reason why I keep doing all these videos
I'm super fortunate that every day I get
to load up my comments and just see tons
of love from you guys and knowing that
the work you know back to the very first
question about being lazy you know it's
not about being lazy about having
unimportant goals knowing that the work
that I do is meaningful to you helps
keep me going every day and so I
appreciate the love looking forward to
hitting the million mark and that if you
have ideas on what we should do for
hitting a million subscribers let me
know not in the live chat cuz it's gonna
disappear but but once this video goes
it gets processed and goes public I
guess you can leave in the comments
below
getting some ideas because the initial
go is a hit a million by the end of the
year it looks like we're gonna do that
in November sometime so I'm pretty I'm
pretty pumped excited by that hit
Nichols but thank you guys again for the
love happy Friday hope you have a great
close to the week hope you use this to
go do something amazing with your day
today I know I'm gonna carry
worth the energy and now I'm gonna go
spend some time with my wife
thank you guys I love I believe in you
hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever you're one where it is
much love I'll see you soon